welcome to this video playing the tech
GM and he is a grandmaster am I'm
playing Julien's auction he had me
playing Julian arched and this is great
yeah one of the great British players he
has to be tired from competitive chess
for a number of years concentrating on
unknown on scholastic chess if I'm not
mistaken in London I believe and he's
the the most famous player to regularly
employ the Trump off scheme like he did
here I'm so playing against the Trump
offski legend and I'm screwing it up
perfectly probably he's got a quick F
for coming maybe it's good to see him
playing and here
really was a very successful player in
the 90s 80s and 90s known for his sharp
attacking style he managed to get good
attacking positions even out of this
this kind of not so well regarded
openings like the Tchaikovsky nowadays
it's perfectly acceptable but back then
they yeah it wasn't considered a great
opening but he he made it made it
popular yeah and what I'm doing here is
not great playing too many pawn moves
but he has got threats Knight B 5 + g5 I
know it looks terrible but I wanted to
prevent a forum he's on the way on the
way with the night over to in to d5
okay night III I'm going to retreat it
may be castles fire he has the he has
all the opportunities in the world to go
to f5 very ugly
yeah I take the tech GM this is very
fitting he's an excellent attacking
player I would defy for surprising
this is the system I said didn't expect
I mean he bits and it's a great position
for white but I thought he would keep
his options open but maybe the pressure
on d4 was was too too big okay yeah so I
need to take cover f5 if he's got
everything yet towards the square and of
course he's threatening Knight xe7
just this simple move takes that he will
take with the pawn and my queen it does
not have a scram Queen f6 is not h5
coming okay it would be great if I
wouldn't have great it's not great I was
trying to say that in flag default h5
would be a relatively good and
positionally but it's it's very
questionable that I I live to see this
kind of ideas
now eh fine oh no maybe it is good but
it certainly is better for white or this
but I'm not sure if it was the maximum
it looked like entirely unplayable okay
if I go here he might play f6 yeah
better not of course he has gained the
e4 square now for the night which is
problem I'd like him to to play him yeah
I actually can play that now f5 is
hanging I'm not sure that it was good to
allow that I can take here now yeah I
know but I mean I know that he can play
Knight takes the aid but okay I can also
just take he actually and it's not so
bad check
I'm sorry yeah it's um it's weird I'm
still I'm still in the game okay Wow I
take it takes with the Queen or what no
I mean I can't play in five even I made
on G - okay the position is starting to
be good for black amazing me
1:14
okay cautious might play Queenie six it
didn't okay but I'm threatening f3m so
I'm not going to cover c7 yeah he lost
the threat year I was outplayed
completely that's deadly now rook takes
rook takes Queen III and it's made on
Jan it doesn't have meaning doesn't have
a check or anything to to defend that
white resides yeah I was completely
outplayed yeah he knows this opening
inside out so I'm probably in big
trouble here already it's simply too
much weaknesses this this kind of stuff
I don't I don't know the opening really
that's I know that you can play sort of
like that but I don't know it know
precisely yeah yeah it's tricky I'm not
very developed and a CF for coming so
let's say I would play him I don't know
nothing moves Bishop somewhere is seven
I was afraid that he would just go here
maybe I can take the form but that's
risky really yeah I was afraid of a
false I went g5 but this is probably the
case of the cube being more dangerous
than the disease yeah 95 and this is
terribly slow
Deary decided to play d5 you know it
keeps it keeps the advantage
no no doubt yeah probably that's alright
I mean look at look at this I'm terribly
weakened this is a case where a single
pawn position is just deciding the
evaluation of the game if I could could
pull some some sort of joke a card and
play jeez g6 a g5 back to g6 the
position immediately switches to being
great for black but with the pawn on d5
it looks terrible and yeah here I don't
know I mean this looks so ugly I'm not
sure it's it's a case where so many
moves look good the nights that are
ideally place they look at the the
critical squares and wonder computer has
a completely wacky line it wants to play
Queen a 4c 400 tech c7 it's maybe maybe
good but but well okay what he did keeps
keeps an edge that's absolutely no
question if I take the problem is I
thought this would be the problem
because this looks just awful but maybe
maybe I'm not losing out right yeah but
it's it's terrible looking okay who p8
yeah and this I don't know I don't know
maybe it is a good idea to just drop it
back yeah that is a good idea actually
and now go for this this is an excellent
positional idea what white wants to
achieve and this would be the ideal
scenario exchange the light squared
bishop and then put it on f5 so that at
the end you have a knight on f5 against
this rotten Bishop on f6 so just to
illustrate the idea I don't think I can
do anything against it anyway let's say
something like that for example and this
is what white wants to achieve yeah
something something like that would be
the dream scenario and this is probably
achievable if you go with Bishop b2 can
this this is really helping me a bit as
if you look at this this is not so
terrible anymore
I'm worse but it's not losing outright
the bishop is bad but it might be
activated I can even consider to drop a
pawn here to to activate and then this
Queen g7 maybe this is far better than
what I had before still not great but
better
yeah man here yeah he's still better
only after g4 this is this was his miss
he he missed that I can play g4 he
probably should do it himself and then
and then go from there yeah I'm really
boxed in here I cannot move the bishop
ever because of f6 probably and if I
cannot move the bishop I cannot move the
Queen because it always needs to protect
the bishop and he can just go here yeah
excellent yeah and here the hizzle G
just overlooked the move and now I'm I'm
check yeah the problem is that the spawn
is a bit weak so we cannot exchange
Queens changing Queens would drop the
pawn
yeah here I'm already playing for win
black is better now if you went downhill
really quickly it's very often that you
that you see that you clearly spoiled an
excellent position and then um and then
you even allow more than then you should
yeah around here black is winning on the
g4 and that is too much it probably has
some way to to keep keep it going at
this point he shouldn't lose outright
maybe he should just go for for
something like that get to get to get
something going on the C file yeah but I
will get the pony something like that is
not bad at all if he takes he will he
will fall fall on you to him a bad
attack yeah he had hit me in the back
completely but then loudest reform
alright
that was an interesting game thanks for
watching